you're playing William Hartnell the
first doctor and adventure in space and
time what does it feel like to be taking
on such a huge role as that well I I
didn't realize when I took it on that
the amount of interest there would be
all I knew is that Mark invited me to do
it just over a year ago and I just said
yes very quickly before he changed his
mind and because I remember William
Hartnell and not only is Doctor Who but
as one of our finest character screen
actors in the 50s and 60s so I knew of
him and I knew his work so I felt I felt
a big sense of responsibility not only
to to honor his memory and for a sake of
his family but also as a man and also as
an actor I saw the script and I thought
this is something special but you never
know how film turns out and sometimes
you do things and if they don't turn out
as you'd imagined either for better or
for worse but this the response to this
adventure in space and time that they're
in the cinema screening the other day
when I saw it was absolutely amazing I
think everyone was very moved and
untouched by the way the fans took to it
because we wanted it to be right with
all the fans because you know they've
followed the series I mean for 50 years
it did feel quite a responsibility as I
said and we hope that when it finally
goes on there later this week that the
fans will will take to it and think
we've done a good job absolutely sure
they will do it had a rapturous applause
so far from the screening at the BFI of
course this leads us into the
anniversary special which leads us into
the new doctor later in the year what do
you think of the choice of Peter Capaldi
as the next Doctor well when we were
part way through the filming
Peter pay the studio visit
because seizing a friend of Mount Gators
and not invited him to come along
because he asked if he could because I
spoke to him I've never met him before
what a delightful guy he was and I
realized he was a lifelong Doctor Who
fan and he was he watched a bit of
filming and was very nice about it
because at that time he didn't know he
was going to be the doc and we certainly
didn't but but when it was announced I
thought well yes he just makes perfect
sentences he's just got all the
qualities you need and apart from being
a brilliant actor so I think he's going
to be great
you